now like I said this is a great sort of
segue into the fact that well if you've
got one form why do you care about
giving it a name if there are other
forms and there are other forms now in
the scope of attention to course there's
only one other form that I'm going to
tell you about okay and you probably be
relieved by the time you get to this
second formula okay this is hard my
brain hurts a little bit I don't even
want to get to this third form which is
a shame the third form I think is the
best one but if you want I can explain
it later
this is rectangular form right this next
form is called again it's got a bunch of
different ends but my favorite just like
rectangular frame my favorite name for
the next thing is called polar form okay
now drool for me please another egg and
diagram
so the way it says I dotted here because
when I first introduces it to us as a
low derail it's kind of like well yes
these are all of the numbers these are
all of them like what is this where is
this coming from
does it even exist like you can't
measure it you can't say ah yeah I grew
i grew i centimeters this year which I
did because I didn't grow at all right
like what does that mean
can I speak or defy it so I put it as a
dollar access it represent it's
something different but there's no
reason why you have to have even if a
few can phone for each other ones just
want to highlight its difference now on
this new our gang diagram and again
let's make sure we represent the imagine
you've found the real part and label
them as such let's pick out a point
let's grab that point and if I'm cool
this guy over here X plus I 1 right I
can represent this in a different way
using a different pair of decimal
expansions of different pair of numbers
if I imagine this point on the
circumference oh okay now just pause
with me for a second I'm gonna draw this
circle in but you're immediately gonna
ask why why would you do that like what
makes you think that
okay now I'm welcome to the answer just
yet but I hope I justify it for you
enough by going back to what Harry said
before now we know there are lots of
ways to write a straight line you've let
this under linear functions earlier this
year
okay this form of course is called this
is this is slope-intercept form right
give me another one
general form right so that's fine give
me another one
quite radiant give me a Nolan to point
give me
you can't pick up another one really
come on haven't you met this one
this guy's useful what's this one corner
no business calling this is intercept
form right for those of you I'm just
judging by the looks on your faces right
if you let X equal zero you let X equal
zero right why for what reason would you
let X equal zero to find the y intercept
right so x equals zero this that
disappears
so what's y equal to so some value right
so ephemeral what is it when y equals
zero why would you let why cuz you're
why would you do that to find the x
intercept when y equals zero X is going
to be that's kind of useful okay now
that's a demonstration right why do we
have 5y five forms for the same thing
it's all you could let the same line in
five different ways because depending on
the way you write it it's useful for a
different purpose
do you agree right um again French guy
on replay right here's quite about
mathematics is description of what
mathematics is is mathematics is the art
of giving do same name to different
things
let's keep the art of giving the same
name to different things
his principle was you look at um you
look at who's away okay Jack is
reasonably wait okay you saw that work
on my fly through the air
it flew through the air what shape did
it make it made a you could fire a host
through the air would make the same
thing you could fire a rocket around the
Sun and it would make the same shape and
Mathemagician say all the same object
they are all the same object actually
any object under the force of gravity if
it has the right acceleration trace that
problem now we have the art of giving
the same names of four things but also
taking the same object and looking at it
from different angles because every time
you get a new angle you gain insight
right now that's what polar form is
about so for now put to one side why you
would do this and have the expectation
the reason will become clear okay
because it will I promise
now let's come back I said imagine it on
the circumference of a circle draw the
circle for me now it's sensor at the
origin so it's going to look something
like this okay now when you've got it on
the circumference of a circle you can
see hey wait a second I'm used to
expressing 2.8 Cartesian coordinates in
terms of a circle except I'm usually
used to the unit circle right which
means greatest one okay but let's be a
bit more general than that because we
don't expect that it has to be on a
circle of radius one so I'm just gonna
call the radius now on the unit circle
what are the X&Y coordinates again any
point of the circumference
you're gonna use three firkins right you
may remember a widened up key because I
don't want to cloudy right now you may
remember it's cos theta sine theta maybe
the way you remember that was that even
thought if any cool just like accident
my mom but where it comes from and you
should have noted this well enough is
extension soon to prove it is this right
angle triangle in here
that's what cousin side are about right
there they highly inviting the triangles
you know where's the right of your
triangle a circle answer they're
everywhere
so if I define theta as this angle here
can you show me how I get because in the
side that what's this distance have a
look this distance is X right it's the
real part of the complex number okay but
using trig I can say wherever a hold on
a set in this side and this side are
connected with what ratio this is the
jason and i hypotenuse this is cosine
right so because cos theta because theta
is x on are adjacent over hypotenuse I
can rewrite this with X as a subject
it's cause they don't does that make
sense
sir R cos theta is another way that I
can write x and in the same way what's
this distance up here this is well I'm
labeling it Y but I can use treat to
show in the same way that's as R sine
theta right now it looks more
complicated but using these I can say
instead of writing it in rectangular
form X plus iy and my two numbers are
horizontal position and vertical
position I can write it using these I'm
just going to substitute them straight
in right instead of writing X I'm gonna
write ah cause speed up instead of
writing I why
I'm gonna write I times all Scythians
that make sense right because I and
there's wire right sir I via clearly I
have a common factor namely and I'm
gonna write something in a second just
so that you recognize it but I actively
discourage you from using it so watch
out have a look here theta right feet is
going to be the same for both of me
these two sides may inhabit same
triangle right so whatever that fear is
it's going to be the same for each of
these it's not like you got one thing
here in another feet of it okay
so people get really sick of writing cuz
I sign cause my sign so they contract it
like this they pronounce it sis which
basically expresses how I feel about
this because I discourage you from using
this here's one okay I'll give you two
reasons number one for all of you who
are going to study mathematics it boy
are they gonna cane you from writing
that okay because it's not really
accepted in the board of mathematical
community it's an ice pack and it's
faster okay but they're not gonna be
happy with you doing that so if you've
got engineering or science degree
anywhere in your future here is this
from your mind okay secondly secondly
what's the point of writing it like this
what's the point of complex numbers and
the answer is it's about saying look
there's two parts oops there's an X and
there's an I won right there's a cos
theta and there's an I sine theta
they're two different pieces I've been
trying to leave it to you the fact that
I don't like every other real number n
bar complex that goes refused to be suit
fighting this way okay but do you see
that this way of writing it quicker as
it is and mathematicians love speed
because they are favors
lazy it kind of takes away from the fact
that actually there's two bits there's
two bits they're supposed to be separate
okay so that is why sometimes you will
see this you'll see some textbooks use
some exams even use it so you need to
know what it means it means this but I
personally wouldn't be caught dead
writing it except to tell you hey this
is what it means okay
so in case you see it now you know how
to interpret it
but even though it's gonna take you a
whole two and a half seconds longer I'm
gonna insist in this classroom you write
cos theta plus cosine beta okay is
anyone know why it's called polar form a
planet it's got two poles doesn't it
it's got what some other two poles but
popularly speaking you've got the North
Pole and South Pole
right now we use these 2 poles to
describe every point on the surface of
the planet just using two numbers right
I just need to know what angle of
rotation Yeah right so this is what
we're compass bearings come from so how
far are you away from north or how far
are you away from yourself okay and then
you've got this other number what does
this number mean this is a distance
right so this is like how far would you
like me to turn I can turn anywhere you
like right and then once I'm facing in
the right direction theta then I just
want you to tell me how far a walk okay
that's our right so again here like men
complex numbers these methods use assess
with names right because these are such
important ideas we give them other
special names
we call this guy ah we call it the
modulus and if your complex number is Z
we write that as ed with absolute value
signs around and you're like why I'll
get to that in a second and then
secondly this guy down here the angle we
call it the argument okay the argue
modulus argument now remember I said to
you this other names for this so it's
often not called polar form because this
form here depends on our modulus at the
front and an argument in here it's often
also called mod odd so if you hear
someone in the library stressing out on
Friday you don't have a library if you
hear someone outside the MPC stressing
out on Friday and like I had you turned
into more egg form this is what they're
talking about right they're trying to
convert between this way of writing
things and that way or back and forth so
more I form polar form or the same